hey Youtubers, it's Charlie finally some good
news some new international Spider-Man footage
just focusing more on the villain team up
so I'll explain their back stories, but it's
also Stanley's birthday today in honor there
is a new round of the Spider-Man giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything.
What a coincidence that all the Spider-Man
Deadpool stuff is dropping on Stanley's birthday
will be plenty of that going on today, so
this international teaser just features the
shocker a little bit more prominently so I'll
explain his back story, but typically, when
they release the smaller clips, they just
focus more on the action of the film just
going on the little footage that we've seen
of him so far we kind of see this story play
out over the course of the trailers, so you
see Spider-Man getting his ass kicked by shocker
here will run all the school buses somewhere
at his school.
Presumably he's wearing the hoodie.
So this looks like it might be happening before
Captain America Civil War before he gets that
Stark tech suit.
Maybe.
Spider-Man barely crawls away or somehow it
just barely manages to get the upper hand
then later we see.
Spider-Man in the Stark tech suit.
Presumably later in the timeline.
After Captain America Civil War stopping the
bank robbery and we see someone using almost
the exact same technology to get that ATM,
so that might be the shocker to do like he's
slowly coming back in the Spider-Man's life
after he has his new gear.
So looks like Spider-Man just is a much easier
time of taking him down but then we get that
Michael Keaton's vulture line were he's like
times are changing time for us to change to
we see the Donald Glover seen who is probably
playing the prowler teaming up with the other
villains like the shocker.
So it seems like the vulture is like slowly
assembling a villain team up, but the big
rumor is is is the Tinker who helps them with
their technology and.
A lot of this is based on avenger should Towery
invasion technology that's been left over
if you remember way back after the first avengers
film they had that item 47 short or they have
echoes to regular people that were down and
out on their luck.
So they got a should Towery gun and they were
going to use it to rob banks, just because
they felt they had no other options any clear
show "what do I do okay what makes you so
sure signs pointing the right direction sure
to work only said that we deserve better right
way for somebody to give us a chance to change
ourselves right that also kind of reads like
the shocker's character from the comics so
that might have something to do with the shocker's
reason for teaming up with the vulture in
these other characters.
So in the comics is name is Herman Scholz
he was this really brilliant inventor who
drops out of high school that he still amuses
really smart person but it's kind of down
and out on his luck.
So we turn to crime to support himself eventually
gets his ass handed to him thrown in prison
and develops the shocker gauntlets starts
committing even bigger crimes you going for
bigger paydays and starts bumping of the Spider-Man
more taking on the shocker persona Shockey
Shockey shot
and you will soon, but you gun more lives
in the.
So is really good at cracking safes like we
see the fake avengers doing here, but he also
has like up a relatively fluid morality like
he is a bad person doing bad things that he's
not completely evil.
So sometimes when he has.
Spider-Man at his mercy to let him go like
he won't kill him when he has the chance because
he's after some big score he doesn't want
to kill people.
He just wants the money, so very honor amongst
thieves.
Type person that also might have something
to do with the vulture to although based on
the dialogue that Michael Keaton has in all
these trailers he is hardcore.
Do not come after me I will kill everybody
you love.
So he might be the one that crosses the line
like you have all these of their minor villains
like the Tinker the shocker the prowler teaming
up with the vulture and they're all in it
because they like money.
But not because they want to murder a whole
lot of people and that's usually where your
villain team ups fall apart.
You have someone who crosses the line and
then the rest just kind of bail on him and
leave him for the heroes to take down, so
the way they're presenting.
Spider-Man in this first movie is that he's
like still figuring things out.
He's a pretty strong hero he is really amazing
power season avengers level hero but is Tony
Stark continues to joke he still has a long
ways to go let the adults handle this just
be a kid.
So he's probably going to get his ass handed
to him by most of these villains at least
a couple times during the movie before he
finally takes them down with a little bit
of help from uncle Tony, so a lot of trailers
can be a little misleading.
Just remember that even though the vulture
is the big bad of the film.
That doesn't mean that he's going to be like
a mustache twirling villain.
I don't think Michael Keaton would be playing
a character if he were that simple so in the
comics the vulture, yes, very bad person but
he's totally screwed over by his business
partner he's actually appear fairly brilliant
inventor in his own right, get screwed over
by his business partner.
His only recourse is to turn to crime to save
the situation then later in after he's become
the vulture character wearing the flight suit
going up against.
Spider-Man eventually we learn about his family
that he cares about deeply.
So he has grandchildren his grandson has a
terminal illness in the only way he can finance
a cure for him is to commit crimes.
He also kills a gang Lord to save his nephew.
So he's not above crossing the line when it
comes to his family so that I mean that's
really like were the heroes that been worth
like we all care about our families, but there's
a line that you don't cross like you don't
murder people in cold blood.
So just all comes back around to great power,
great responsibility, you guys can let me
know.
Let's talk more about the villains of Spider-Man
homecoming.
What do you think is going to be the point
at which they team up and what you think is
going to be the big point of contention that
causes them to fall apart allowing Tony Stark
and Spider-Man to take them all down because
it sounds like the upgrades that they go through
the course of the movie make them this invincible
bad guy team up, at least from Spider-Man's
perspective like too hardcore for him to take
on by himself, so something bad enough has
to happen for Tony to get up off his ass and
come help.
Spider-Man out like okay I was going to do
this but now things gotten so bad that I need
to put my armor on and step in and given that
Tony causes many problems as he solves it
sounds like the vulture is going to be more
than a match for him, so something can have
to happen because this villain team up to
fall apart.
Usually it's the idea that none of the villains
are or most of the villains don't care about
each other no honor amongst thieves thing
like usually be the one person in the group
has no honor in the rest of them abandon him,
so that sounds like it's going to be the vulture
character but like you said because it's Stanley's
birthday today they announced some special
Deadpool Wolverine movie stuff going on.
So I'll do a video for that next, that might
not post till tomorrow morning.
But this can be all kinds of Wolverine Deadpool
stuff happening early in the year so 2017
starting off rights gonna be awesome.
So I will say congratulations to this week's
Spider-Man giveaway winner a Ryan, you win
a $20 Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel so
I can get your contact details.
There is a new round of the giveaway that
starts now I'll announce the winner when I
post that Wolverine Deadpool video.
So get hype 2017 is going to be so awesome.
I like to go into it, feeling very optimistic
about all the stuff that's coming, especially
given all the sad stuff that's happening late
in this year while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here to watch the longer.
Spider-Man trailers and you can click here
for bran new arrow trailer.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!